كاس العالميين عش تويتر بشهاده مالك
المنصه ورئيسها واهانات الخارجيه الروسيه
ضربت في الكل الاوروبيين والامريين و 25
سؤال مع ليلى احمد زاهر اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اخبار كاس العالم هذه الايام هي اهم الناس
الاكبر والخبر الابراج واللي بيعملوا في
تويتر كمان عنوان مكمل معنا فتخيلوا عيد
لما يجتمعوا الاثنين في خبر واحد طبيعي
يكون عنواننا الاول استخدم كاس العالم
اليوم في حلقه جديده ضمن حلقات مسلسل
التباهي يتكلم معنا النشاط اللي بسبب
المونديال على تويتر والشغل الي عامله
موظفي من الصفر فغردقه كاس العالم كان
موضوع 20 الف تغريده في الثانيه امس
العمل الرائع من فريق تويتر في قياس
معدلات الاستخدام للمنسف تباهي ماسك كملوا
احنا تعودنا خلاص انه بيحب الرسوم
البيانيه
اليوم نشر واحد منها قال انه بيظهر انخفاض
خطاب الكراهيه على المنصه خلال الشهر
الماضي وبارك لموظفي تويتر هذا الانجاز
طبعا لازم ماسك يتباها بهذا الشيء لانه
كثير من منتقديه بيتهموه انه بسبب ارائه
ومواقفه خطاب الكراهيه راح يزيد كانه
بيوريهم انه يعني اللي جالس يصير هو العكس
وعلى سيره الانتقاد فماسك نشر فيديو امس
من مخزن لمنتجات تويتر اللي بيبيعوها
ومكتوب عليها هاشتاج ستاي ووك طبعا ابوك
يعني هذا المصطلح للاسف لسه ما تعرف بس هو
بيطلق على الافكار والمواقف اليسريه
الرافضه والمحاربه والمحاربه للتمييز
اعتمادا على الهويه سواء الجنسيه او
العراقيه او غيرها ومؤخرا صارت بقصد في
المبالغه في الموضوع لحد التطرف يعني كانه
تطرف بس هذا من ناحيه انه الليبراليه
وبعدين ماسك انتقدوا اكثر من مره وصفوا
فيروس وامس نشر فيديو او فيديو عثور وعلى
هذه التيشرتات كانه بيقول للعالم شوفوا
الاداره السابقه زي ما انا كنت بقول لكم
عنهم اداره مو محايده وصاحبه الجيولوجيه
واليوم كم الحمله هذه ونشر صور لنفس
التيشرتات لكن مكتوب عليها ستاي ورك بدل
ستاي وورك جوجل انها بضائع جديده رائعه من
تويتر طبعا يعني عمل وماسك لعب على فرق
الحرف الواحد
[موسيقى]
في مقطع فيديو منتشر وعمل تفاعل جميل جدا
على المنصات وللامير عبد العزيز بن تركي
الفيصل وزير الرياضه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ساعه الماضيه المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه
مو يعني انه قصف الجبهات غريب عليها اصلا
او شيء بس دوز الاهانه الساعات الماضيه
صراحه كان مكثف والمنصه كالعاده حسبها على
التيليجرام اخر اللي ضربت فيهم هم
الاوروبيين اللي سوت برلمانهم الاربعاء
على قرار يصرف روسيا بدوله رائعه للارهاب
بسبب الحرب على اوكرانيا
انا
[تصفيق]
قرار وحركه زي هذه اكيد ما راح تفوتها
زخرفه اللي كتبت على قناتها على التلجرام
مثل ما البرلمان الاوروبي صرنا في روسيا
راعيه للارهاب فانا بقترح تصنيف البرلمان
الاوروبي راعي للحماقه
يعني زخرفه
امس انتشرت اخبار انه خلاص منظمه الصحه
العالميه بتعتزم تغيير اسم جدري القرود من
منقي بوكس الى خبر مصدره من الصدفه
الامريكيين عن مصادر مطلعه قالت انه خلاص
الصحه العالميه هتغير الاسم لازاله وصمه
العار المرتبطه بالاسم منظمه الصحه كانت
من كم شهر قالت انها بتفكر تغير الاسم
عشان الموضوع وصلت العالم لكن بحذف اللي
صاير الان انه في ضغوط اضافيه سببها البيت
الابيض اللي يقول لهم يتغير الاسم عالميا
راح نغيره احنا داخلين مع نفسنا ما
نعتمدكم الوصمه اللي تكلم فيها الامريكان
وغيرهم بيقصدوا فيها انه مسمى جدري القرود
في تمييز على اساس اللون وتلميح لاصل
الفيروس اللي نشا في افريقيا عصمت العار
هذه مخليه كثير ناس يرفضوا حتى التطعيم
بحسب البيت الابيض وعلى فكره ترى هذه مو
اول مره بتغيير اسم فيروس بسبب موضوع وصمت
العار او هذا النوع من الجدل هذا النوع من
الجدل صار قبل كده واحد ترموه من فتره
بعيده لو تذكره مشاهدين انا اكيد ما هنقدر
ننسى يعني ما لحقنا ننسى اصلا فيلم
الفيروس الصيني او كرونه وكل الجدل اللي
صار عليه طيب زي ما سمعتوا الخبر ما في
سيره روسيا باي شكل ما لهم دخل يعني جماعه
اذا رغم كده خروف استغلته وحذفت لها اهانه
على الامريكيين وبرده على تلجرام كتبت انه
كجزء من مكافحه وسمه العار منظمه الصحه
العالميه راح تغير تسميه الجدري القرود
الى ام بوكس وقالت لترى هذه المره ايش
القصه حقوق القرده هي المنتهكه ولا
المسؤولين الامريكيين شعروا بالانتهاك
لانه شايفين انه الموضوع بيمسهم
قصدي طبعا القرده
[موسيقى]
طيب مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لموعدنا الاسبوع
مع فقره 25 سؤال ضيفتنا هذا الاسبوع
الفنانه ليلى احمد زاهر انا اترككم مع
اللقاء واعدوا القائم الاحد ان شاء الله
في امان الله
ليلى احمد زاهر 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم
بسرعه من غير تفكير حاضر ظهرت في صورك
الاخيره وانت نحيفه جدا كيف فقدت الوزن
حلو
خمس سنوات عاده هذا الشيء الترسل بنا على
الاطفال كيف كان اكثر او كيف اثر عليك او
كيف كانت تجربتك هلا انا كنت مبسوطه جدا
الشباب
همم لو مثلا حكت لهم حاجه فتوتروا فممكن
يتعصبوا دي اكثر حاجه بوكي فيها لا ما
بيعجبونيش بس بيقعدوا بيهددوني اللي هو
والله العظيم لو عملت كذا ثاني انا هاوريك
كده اوكي
شكلي حلو شكرا قوي ده يعني انا مش عارفه
انت حلوه طبعا اكيد
الشعور انك حلوه يعني ما ما بعرفش ان ممكن
حد يقول على نفسه حلو قوي كده
كثير جاوب على هذا السؤال قالوا نحن حلوين
اوكي يجي لك تحديد النشط جدا على التيك
توك وكثير بيعتبركم انفلونزا ودخيلات على
التمثيل كيف بتردين
وانا صغيره معروف ان انا بامثل وكبرت
واخذت بريك شويه في النصف ورجعت للتمثيل
وتيك توك ده انا يعني اللي خلاني اعمله ان
انا كنت في الكرونه كلنا كنا زهقانين كلنا
كنا بنعمل تيك توك حتى انا الاكونت بتاعي
ما كنتش عارفه
من صحابي اللي عمله لي اصلا وانا ما كنتش
متضايق اخوان انا عادي انا بانزل فيديوهات
زي زي اي احد واا
وبانزل زهقانه
يعني الحمد لله ههه
معهم همم هند صبري همم
دنيا سمير غانم حلوه
وكريم عبد العزيز واحمد عز اوكي حلوين
ممثل ونجمه او ممثله او نجمه سوشيال ميديا
الان هتدخلي عالم الغناء كمان همم
ممكن هتصيري مغنيه خلاص ممكن نقول لا يعني
هو انا يعني بغني وبامثل بس ما اعتقدش
هابقى مغنيه بس او ممثله بس يعني حفلات
ليلى مش عارفه ممكن على فكره ممكن جدا مع
الوقت بس ما اعتقدش ان هو همم
كثير قوي طيب مقارنه جدا من اختك ملاك
ولكن مرت عليكم
لسه برده بسرعه السؤال ده لا كل اللي
بريحي اااه في واحده ربنا يسامحها ههه او
او انا بشكرها يعني لانها خليتني اقرب من
اختي اكثر هي كانت
بتوقع ما بيننا او انا كنت صغيره يعني وفي
الفتره دي ملك ما كانتش ما كناش عارفين ما
كانش فيه ايه وافكار مني كيشن ما بين قوي
فكانت الفتره دي يعني هي مش فاهماني وانا
لما باقول لها ان انا متضايقه من كذا تقول
لي لا انت غلطانه فهي مش بتريحني او مش
فاهماني صاحبتي دي كانت بتقول لي لا انت
صح او بتاع ايا كان انا كنت صح ولا غلط بس
همم في طريقه معينه تريحي بها اللي قدامك
وتعرفيني ان هو غلطان من غير ما تقفليه
اوكي هي كانت مش عارفين نتعامل مع بعض
صحبتي دي كانت بتريحني وبتاع فعلا انا كنت
همم يعني مستريحه مع صاحبتي ومتضايقه من
اختي ان انا مش معي صاحبتي كانت بتسخني
على اختي هي مش بتحبك هي هي هي وانا طبعا
غلطانه جدا جدا جدا لان ملك دي احلى واحده
في حياتي واقرب واحده لي واحده بتح يعني
الثانيه دي كانت بصراحه اا ربنا يبعد يعني
طبعا قطعت علاقتي بها تماما واا ربنا
يسامحها بقى ههه اكثر فكره مغلوطه عنك
اكثر فتره ايه فكره مغلوطه عنك فكره
مغلوطه عني همم
حاجه الناس بتقول عليا وهي مش صاحيه
همم
ممكن مثلا ان انا ممكن يقول ان انا تنكه
مش عارفه انا مش عارفه بس ممكن يعني
طيب اوكي ممكن يفهمه غلط يعني ممكن من
الصوره كده يقول لك لا دي تنكه دي اوكي طب
نشرح بس مش مصري
موهوبه جدا جدا وشاطره جدا
وانا دايما بتفرج عليها بيبقى اللي هو مش
مصدقه هي ازاي بتعمل كل ده ازاي ما شاء
الله يعني بتغني وبتعمل استعراضات وبتمثل
وشيز يعني
بشوفها نجمه كبيره جدا ونفسي في يوم من
الايام ابقى ان شاء الله ربعها يعني
فاهمين اقرب صديقه لك في الوسط الفني انا
ما عنديش ناس قريبين
بيبقوا اصحابي وباحبهم جدا جدا
انا اصلا اول مره اجاوب على السؤال ده بس
قبل ما اجاوب عليه انا باطلب من كل حد
بيشوف الانترفيو ده ان هو يقرا لها
الفاتحه ويدعي لها الله يرحمها طبعا
يعني بصي احنا كنا في الساحل وقتها كنا في
الساحل في الصيف يعني وبعدين عرفت الخبر
طبعا اتصدمت نزلنا من الساحل على القاهره
همم
روحت من الجنازه وكل حاجه وبعدين رجعنا
ثاني ساحل علشان اهلي كلهم كانوا هناك
وبتاع فكان لازم ارجع
انا بجد كنت مودي وحش جدا وكنت اللي حبسه
نفسي في الاوضه ما كنتش عايزه احتك بناس
مش عايزه تعمل مع حد كنت متضايقه وكنت
فصادمه
مرت ايام كتير قوي مسفرنا عشان نتبسط وهو
بالنسبه له يعني مش عايز يشوفني متضايقه
وكده عملي مفاجاه وجاب لي
حفله عمرو دياب
وبس وبعدين انا ما كنتش عايزه اروح ايوه
انا باعشق حاجه اسمها عمرو دياب طبعا بس
انا نفسيا ما كنتش قادره اروح
فقعد يقول لي لا قوي
ساعتها ان هو عمل كده عشان بس ابقى مبسوطه
ان ده انا انا طول الوقت باحاول انسى مفكر
حاجه ثانيه او كده
فهد اللي صار يعني
طلعتي من الجنازه على الحفله بس مش هذا
انا عايز اقول لحد النهارده انا انا والله
العظيم وحياه ربنا انا لحد النهارده انا
مش مصدقه ان انا ماتت يلا يرحمها طبعا
ويرحمها الفنان الكبير سمير غانم بصفه في
زوج المستقبل
[موسيقى]
العنوان بس ما بتلاقي وين الهجوم يعني
هجوم انا مش فاهمه والله بس انا باحبها
وهي بتحبني جدا الحمد لله فا- همم انت
تنحب صراحه اغنيه تعبر عنك
لا ما اعرفش ما عندك واحده كده تحسي تعبر
عنك تعبر عني من ناحيه ايه بالضبط اي شيء
تحسي كده انه اه يعني انه تمثل لك الاغنيه
دي او كده
مثلا اذا انت رايقه بتحبي الدندنيها مش
ضروري انه بتعبر عنك بس بتحبيها يعني
ممكن اقول اكثر اغنيه معلقه معي دلوقت
اسمها
جماله بتاعه جوزيف
منه
[ضحك]
اصلا ازاي
اسرع شويه قلت ايه ده اوكي من واحد لعشره
قديش سعادك اسم والدك على تحقيق الشهره
والنجاح
[موسيقى]
يعني انا ممكن اقول 10 ان انا يعني هو هي
مش واثقه ولا اي حاجه بس بابايا راجل
محترم وتقيل ما شاء الله في التمثيل وكده
فانا حتى الناس يعني
لما بيشوفوني في الشارع بيقولوا لي
بيقولوا بنت احمد زاهر بيقول يعني زمان
يقولوا بنت ليلى احمد زاهر لحد دلوقتي
بيقولوا البنت سوري بنت احمد زاهر لحد
دلوقت بيقولوا بنت احمد زيدان عشان انا
بابايا ما شاء الله عليه احد جميل
همم
فالناس عارفه ان انا بنته حتى بامثل او مش
بامثل الناس عارفه ان انا بنت احمد زاهر
ودلوقت بيقولوا لي احمد طبعا بس
الله يخليك هو يا رب في فتره او في فتره
في صغريك فرض عليك والدك التوقف عن
التمثيل ورفض اي عرض للعوده انا زعلت
وقتها كده
جدا يعني بس انا كنت عايزه امثل انا كنت
شايفاه
يعني عارف ان انا موهوبه وقصده ان هو لا
بالعكس بس هو كان صح ان انا اخذ بريك يعني
اوكي يعني حساسيه كانه بيحاول يقضي على
موهبتك
وطموحي اعملت دراما كبيره يعني لما كبرت
لما كبرت فهمته طبعا استاذ ياسر جلال هو
الاقنعه ان انا ارجع بس ايوه كان معدل
صرفك على الملابس في الشهر
[ضحك]
الثاني من برنامج بدائته فنانه اخرى
بنتكلم طبعا
البرنامج جاء لي هو مش مش مثلا
مذيعه فهو السيزن الاول كان هنا السيزون
الثاني ليلى الله اعلم امين
والدتك لانه اماكن قادر
طبعا عن هذا القرار الحمد لله وانت موجوده
الان ما زعلت منه
لا ما زعلتش منه لان انا اي حد في مكانه
وانا قدرت ده يعني انا بالعكس صعب علي
يعني
هو كان خايف يمكن من بكره لان هو ما كانش
قادر دلوقتي ان هو يعمل كده بس ربنا كرم
الحمد لله
لما عمل الصح وسابني طبعا ان هو لو كان
قتلني او مشاني ههه شوف الولد
في حياته يعني اوكي اختك ملك موهوبه لكن
ايش الفرق في الموهبه بينكم هي بتتفوق
عليك
بطريقه مش طبيعيه
لذيذه ومش فايه ملك شاطره جدا في التمثيل
شسفاري تعال انتد اوكي طيب كيف علاقتك
بالقراءه
ههه لا طبعا وحشه جدا
يعني ما بتقراي ابدا انا باكرهها بابا وما
بحبش اقرا اه اوكي لو قدمتي برنامج حواري
مين اول نجم هتستضيف فيه وايش اول سؤال
همم
مين مين مش عارفه ممكن بقى
نقول مين استضيف احد وساله سؤال سؤال عامل
ازاي سؤال انت حابه تعرفي منه
ممكن استضيف هند صبري حلو اقول لها
انت ازاي شاطره كده مثلا
ما شاء الله عليها جميله طيب شكرا قوي
[موسيقى]